To better understand what genetic factors might
be influencing bipolar disorder. A large genome-wide
association study has been conducted using hundreds
of thousands of SNVs. In 3,000 control individuals
who don't have bipolar disorder And 2,000
individuals that have been diagnosed with bipolar
disorder. Although some alleles or variants were
found more often in patients than in controls.
None were convincingly different than would be
expected by chance. So which of the following
is most likely to be true? Now there are multiple answers to this question. So I
want you to check all that you think apply. This could be a little bit tricky
so try to take each answer individually to
critically think about which options are actually viable.